citizens of the reject Nation Tara Erickson
is back once again hi we are gonna watch Monsters
University for the 10th anniversary I didn't
even realize until I pulled it up on Disney
P we are celebrating a a milestone today cool
I didn't know that so before we hop into the
skies leave a like on the video and after
you leave a like make sure to subscribe and
also ring that bell ring the bell now if we
could just get the song to pop up again in
this movie like it did in the water boy would
be good it was the best also while you're
at it be sure to check out Terra on social
media on the YouTubes and check out La eats
and drinks which is Tara's online food Excursion
Extravaganza and if you want to get the full
experience of Monsters University with us
see everything that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com the
real rejects sync up with your own copy it's
a lot of fun over there we also got a bunch
more stuff that we react to and review and
all that good stuff watch lungs reaction highlights
included without further Ado Tara are you
ready to go back to school ready to get schooled
not really but I am ready for Monsters me
too let's do this thing
frighten Elementary
it's so pretty where they live I know is it
fall is it Autumn I want to go to there is
it almost Halloween Mike Wazowski thanks oh
my God he's so cute little monkey get your
field trip buddy Jeremy you and me okay no
biggie Haley oh somebody be Mike's friend
Russell Wazowski we carpool oh oh it looks
like it's you and me again
Mikey's so sweet
we scare because we care I'm in a haunted
house Facebook group called that this is where
we collect the scream energy to power our
whole world whose job it is to go get that
scream [Music] yes
hahaha
oh
dang it the grown-up adult Monsters the a
squad I just happen to be a scare I learned
everything I know from my school Monsters
University it's the best scaring school there
is you wish via Tech's the best stop right
there don't cross over that safety line human
children are extremely toxic whoa [Music]
foreign
you don't belong on a scare floor ah he's
just as much a monster as you yeah and also
where's the teacher Mrs Graves Michael went
over the line yes
[Music] go wrong yes atta boy Mike [Music]
good distraction
[Music]
what
you look so happy oh my God that's the greatest
face it's a nice transition there I didn't
even know you were in there wow I didn't even
know you were in there nice not bad that's
nice hey he's not invisible anymore that's
some Beautiful Textures in this too yes everything
feels like you could squish it [Music]
varsity band killing it there absolutely some
monsters probably got to join the band
it's a little Samwise moment cute if I take
one step further oh [Music] one small step
for the University one giant leap for Mike
Wazowski for Monster kind
this is a gorgeous campus oh my God so pretty
what where are they this is awesome yeah what
part of the country is this tell us now we
want to go there learn
[Music] ing oh that's cool making doors let
the crown jewel of mu the scaring schools
look at the teeth on that Arch this is what
it was like for us at scare Academy you know
scare games a super intense scaring competition
they're crazy dangerous you get a chance to
prove that you are the best so fired up right
now yeah roar oh no what what hey there I'm
your roomie name's Randy Boggs take whichever
bed you want I wanted you to have first dibs
oh if I do that in scaring class I'll be a
joke no it's it's totally great you gotta
use it really yeah but look at the glasses
they give it away yeah yeah man I can't wait
to get started oh that looks so pretty why
does this have to be not real I know I want
to go there where you want to go I want them
to build that and like just like you can go
in there and like eat food eat Monsters University
food oh my God please make it happen I can't
be late on the first day oh oh it me sluggy
needs some shoes or something skates yeah
or a hoverboard I am Professor Knight and
I do not scare easily
whoa
Professor McGonagall she's only broke the
all-time scare record with the screaming that
very can whoa at the end of the semester there
will be a final exam fail that exam and you
are out of the scaring program oh limited
time kids who can tell me the properties of
an effective Roar the Roars resonance the
duration of the Roar and the
[Music]
I love him Mr Sullivan Jimmy Sullivan like
Bill Sullivan the scarer he's my dad oh Nepal
baby
aren't you
ready
oh are they from Fear Tech your attack dummies
oh sorry about that buddy why are you in my
room your room this is my this is not my room
oh aren't you the Scare Pig You're Gonna Take
It To The River Roar Omega Roar the top fraternity
on campus a mega roar now we're on an adventure
wow [Music]
oh my God I want to live in this land so bad
like everything is so pretty and awesome rarely
have I wanted to just jump into the screen
more
[Music] yes
ten points to Spooky door you want your state
of Kai material freshman thanks no no no no
no he's an Omega owl guy we saw him first
no way we did I'll take it from here Johnny
Worthington president of Roar Omega Roar Hey
You See Me Ride the pig but you might want
to hang out with someone a little more your
speed they look fun uh I'm a hater nah I'm
gonna scare circles around you this year okay
I'd like to see that you will yeah go hang
out with Nathan Philly and you jerk there's
nothing that'll get you going like spite now
here is a Monster who looks like a scarer
uh-huh I think you should scare people that
way what's up kids monster
just do that take out your retainer and wave
it around yeah pretty scary yeah embrace the
horrors of Orthodontics
[Music] you gotta apply yourself Sullivan
so many great details like I just want to
pause and just scrub all the frames so awesome
zombie snob silverback gorilla yes yes way
to go Mike one frightening face there's not
a scare and make who's fallen behind I'm gonna
destroy that guy well then you'll get this
back right away it's time to start delivering
on that Sullivan name oh you know what Sully
turn is back on Mike but I guarantee you Mike's
not going to turn his back on solely I believe
you Tara in the scare simulator
oh no oh a child's scarier than any of them
what is that thing
oh here we go catch it all the time in the
world yeah all the Time in the World Is Right
holy junk oh my God the scream all the screams
are in there
oh this is not good I'm a seven-year-old boy
this particular child is afraid of snakes
emit would make him cry alerting his parents
exposing the Monster World destroying Life
as We Know It uh I cannot recommend that you
continue in the scaring program good day but
I'm a Sullivan I'm sure your family will be
very disappointed find a new Legacy although
to be fair they could have stored those more
safely yeah like in a cabinet what do you
lack is something that cannot be taught you're
not scary oh you will not be continuing in
the scaring program let me try the simulator
I'll surprise you I doubt that very much oh
we'll see about that lady Dragon Lady you
got it coming for you some say that a career
is a scream can designer is boring unchallenging
a waste of a monster's potential open your
taxes uh Rich history of scream can design
oh it's so sad he has to stare why does window
at straight at the school look scary I know
right yes yeah man put your name in the tri-wizard
cup Harry get in there the Goblet of Fire
we're closing down sign up so we'll see you
all wait signing up oh yes the next winning
fraternity of the scare games the brothers
my brothers of uzma Kappa
yeah kid looks like Russell if I win you let
me back on the scaring program and what would
that prove that you were wrong yeah that you
suck if you win I will let your entire team
into the scare program uh Sully you got to
get in there now man yeah if you lose you
will leave Monsters University deal all right
Mike we need six guys right sorry Chief we
count bodies not heads that dude counts as
one [Music] ouch thank goodness I need you
on my team I'm already on a team uh that's
how it all happens the star player has just
arrived no way we're shutting down signups
okay is he on your team or not fine yes she's
on my team Hmm this is a fraternity house
hey there teams I bet you it's so clean in
there I love that there this is okay technically
we haven't actually had a party here yet but
when we do we'll be ready
oh man excellent timing do you pledge your
souls to the uzma Kappa Brotherhood wow oh
geez Mom we're doing an initiation well carry
on just pretend I'm not here this is my mom's
house excellent can't wait to start scaring
with you Brothers [Music]
oh all right Sally thank you sir you're gonna
buy another replace that it's the first event
of the scare games where do they want us to
meet of all the sewers on campus this one
has always been my favorite it's called sewer
hunting
that looks awesome [Music] [Applause] underground
monster fights the toxic [Applause]
yeah movie and in real life
I'm gonna beat you over that Finish Line get
ready to eat my dust one last thing scares
work in the dark oh man yes oh nice good luck
ladies thanks we're gonna rip you to pieces
what yep oh
why are you guys going so fast shouldn't you
like slow and precise
oh God it's gonna be tough for the slithery
ones [Music] mustache that bubble butt oh
geez oh my goodness [Music] no help him oh
man go go go come on get out of there
oh gosh this looks so painful
[Music] what does that do to your insides
oh whoa
take that without you are you Delirious I
beat you your whole team has to cross the
finish line
yeah guys who's my Kappa has been eliminated
no wow Jaws State Akai has been disqualified
what the use of illegal protective gel is
cause for elimination
is back in the games it's a miracle truly
truly a miracle your luck will run out eventually
not if you guys learned to work together as
a team that's right whip him into shape Mike
in the next event if even one of us gets caught
we're all out do exactly what I do foreign
love it oh boy and in this event you do not
want to get caught by the librarian quiet
oh those teeth What's So Scary About a little
old library
yeah she looks like Ursula I said oh yeah
whoa
poor unfortunate soul [Music] s
[Music] oh man oh come on oh Jesus jump [Music]
all right damn it [Music]
[Music]
the Only Rule is don't get caught so noticed
and caught are different now go get it kids
oh my goodness goodness somebody's gotta get
the flag though [Music] we did it didn't we
forgot the flag Mike ah what and who's my
Kappa live to scare another day
it's starting to surprise her hello
these guys are crazy yeah buddy yeah party
like mascara take that retainer Out Boy let's
do this yeah [Music] I love the goth club
yeah you're joining his then I would oh [Music]
come on Sullivan Sully
little Gangnam Style yes come on come on he
got the flag for y'all there we go Sully come
on yes come on buddy let's go [Music] oh
is there like a little one that's like him
oh anywhere
that's a great POV it's awesome the surprise
team of the scare games who's macappa come
on over guys you did it goes I thought you
were a bunch of nobodies but boy was I wrong
let's hear it for uzma Kappa [Applause] do
it man is that gack what what wow
oh man
I find that kind of adorable but I know it's
embarrassing for them
[Music] you guys they're the bad guys yeah
these guys jerks I want you to stop making
us look like fools hey you're making yourselves
look like fools cease and desist with our
likeness rights yeah if you really want to
work for a scare company they're always hiring
in the mail room nope you're gonna work in
the mail room Nathan Fillion no matter how
much we train we'll never look like them we're
built for other things oh 1200 Dark Avenue
can't let the bullies win yeah it takes nothing
to be born scary we're going on a little field
trip
I love the designs of their cars I got like
two three grills or like extra headlight eyes
have fun kids Obama always has rollers in
her hair
yeah that's right Mom foreign
that's the real terror getting arrested yeah
Locked In The Slammer
all right yeah put put it to the real test
get in a door and scare a kid they're going
into the human world and they don't even look
scared Yeah man they prose oh yeah they're
gonna learn so much the best scare is use
their differences to their advantage ah yeah
wowie cool Bob Gunderson I still have his
rookie card me too doesn't have a speed anymore
but this technique is Flawless ah did we just
become best friends bonding I've been a real
jerk so have I we could be a great team we
just need to start working together oh what
what are you doing up there I can't go back
to jail getting inspired [Music]
provide a distraction somehow hey there you
go Sully there we go yeah start the car stop
the bar the car start the car oh okay oh [Music]
okay go um
let's spray let's do it yeah it's breaking
everywhere we can oh all right now we're getting
the juice heck yeah all right new threads
that's what I'm talking about fresh drips
looking good
looking more than okay Sully's never look
so happy the kids in the bathroom
[Music] I love it it's our Rocky Montage scare
the little kid a boy's a teenager huh the
teenager will rip you apart yes [Music]
that's awesome yes stay hidden take cover
and stay out of sight you got 10 seconds kiosk
pile of leaves standing out in the open hey
angry poodle gas clown yes in the morning
that's what I'm talking about killing it nice
hey
yes use those cups
time to go to work all right my man [Music]
I love this drum line with this Montage yeah
I want to see the band yeah
ah damn tough luck Chris Kringle
sounds good also good damn it also good not
bad you've been taught well which leads us
to the final event the scare simulator will
prove who's the best Mike has never gotten
his chance after you lose no one will remember
you maybe but when you lose no one will let
you forget it boy that is a good point
it is
you're gonna talk to this guy yeah who's mccapp
is going to be huge in no time I hope there's
no hard feelings tomorrow each of you must
prove that you are undeniably scary one of
you is not
Mike no he works harder than anyone do you
think he's scary he's the heart and soul of
the team do you think he's scary is he any
more or less scarier than the other ones yeah
I mean there's plenty in there that don't
look scary time to forget all that just reach
deep down and let the scare you out now Mike
goes into training oh you're thinking again
from the gut yeah [Music] come on
this is studying we're working here each simulated
scare has been set to the highest difficulty
level Oh no just like we planned I'll go first
then Don Mike's the one who started all this
and I think it's only right if he's the one
who finishes it yeah Mike Finn is strong yeah
[Music] [Applause] [Music] oh [Music] remember
your training
[Music]
not great [Music] go [Music] all right that
was solid okay
[Music] oh oh slick moves okay
[Applause] oh yes oh cool use those break
dance skills ah awesome [Music]
oh come on you got that kick good yeah Sullivan
and bobs oh no foreshadowing yeah
child looks familiar somehow is that an Easter
egg [Music]
oh it sounds like a lion and Thunder
yeah buddy there you go that's the last time
I lose to you Sullivan and the Rivalry is
born don't worry about anyone else just go
out there and show them what Mike Wazowski
can do yeah nice pep talk soul you can do
it buddy your team's got your back don't take
the loss too hard you never belonged here
anyway good sportsmanship [Music] yeah juice
him up he's got fuel now [Music] oh please
don't mess up what are we what was the plan
[Music]
okay oh boy belong on a scare floor no one
will remember you you're not scary come on
yes
yes there you go
take that that Hard Scrabble yeah man triple
word score [Music] [Applause]
yeah my you did it oh [Music] oh oh
that's gonna be weird you're gonna be your
teammate's father-in-law right her stepfather
there you go get plenty of rest kiddo You
Haven't Seen the Last of Mike Wazowski
what oh did he rig it
[Applause] damn it I was ah damn I was just
I was thinking like why are my settings different
did you do this I ouch why did you do this
you'll get better and better I'm as scary
as you you just wanted to help yourself well
what was I supposed to do let the whole team
fail because you don't have it
oh that burns yeah [Music] he could have done
it
y'all go come clean give him another shot
oh all right yeah he's gonna go through the
real thing you did what my team had nothing
to do with it it was all me I expect you off
campus by tomorrow is that Helen Mirren oh
yeah might be what's going on someone broke
into the door lab what
oh no oh yeah oh yes oh dude [Music] thank
you
you look funny oh
no oh my goodness no oh God
damn
what can you do this is a nice this is a nightmare
a toxicity yeah wait [Music]
misdirection of course do it Solly [Music]
Mike
no what Mike uh oh
[Music] or a Sasquatch
yes so pretty and so spooky spooky is pretty
John yes my mistake of course it is come on
buddy let's get you out of here you were right
they weren't scared of me I did everything
right I wanted it more than anyone I could
show everybody that that Mike Wazowski is
something special and I'm just not oh they're
just special in a different way you'll never
know what it's like to fail because you were
born a Sullivan yeah I'm a Sullivan I'm the
Sullivan who flunked every test the one who
got kicked out of the program the one who
was so afraid to let everyone down that I
cheated yeah I asked Gary Mike but most of
the time I'm scared I'm terrified
oh how come you never told me that before
we weren't friends before
[Music]
[Music] Sully here we go called him Sully
yes
they're still in there until the authorities
arrive this store stays off no oh boy what
if we scare them I mean really scare them
we could generate enough scream to power the
door from this side yeah ah they're adults
I can't do this yes you can just follow my
lead let's go let's do this
uh-huh yes nice oh creepy playing the hits
yeah all the tropes of a scary movie are you
ready Mike I can't yes you can stop being
a Sullivan and start being you yes nice
amazing yeah buddy oh my goodness there you
go yeah that's some nuclear scaring foreign
oh my goodness
oh
man
take that lady you only got one in your life
yeah who's scared now yeah
oh nah that's Monsters Inc now
[Music]
oh
what's gonna happen to them that's for the
University president to decide hey what's
up expelled yeah we really messed up art scrabble's
letting us into the scare program hey he invited
us to join next semester congratulations guys
and that's not the only piece of good news
Sherry and I are engaged I don't want you
to think of me as your new Dad after all we're
fraternity brothers first this is so weird
it is you'll keep in touch hit no you're the
scariest bunch of monsters I have ever met
hmm don't let anyone tell you different [Music]
that's so sweet y'all are okay I'm okay just
being okay
so long so so long huh have we seen a Pizza
Planet truck anywhere hey I don't know a single
scarer who can do what you do and you think
you're just okay you pulled off the biggest
scare this school has ever seen that wasn't
me that was you it was us you're not scary
not even a little but you are fearless yes
and if Hard Scrabble can't see that then she
could I can just what yeah the two of you
did something together that no one has ever
done before you surprised me there is nothing
I can do for you now except perhaps wish you
luck oh you guys can go to Fear Tech now yeah
man there is still one way we can work at
a scare company oh the mail room yep yep you're
always hiring in the mail
this is better than I ever imagined I think
we break the all-time record in our first
year I'm talking about the record for letters
delivered all right there he is [Music] yes
working your way up the ranks oh got a number
too ah
flies with chili cheese fries scare tryouts
yes screaming in the rain [Music]
oh oh Celia good luck on your first bite thanks
fellas [Music] step over the line you coming
coach you better believe it [Music]
they get their own cards and everything well
done I love it very lovely what a delight
that was so good yeah oh it's so cute I feel
so happy for him yeah me too it's funny when
this when this first was coming out I was
like hey you know sequel monsters I'm sure
it'll be fine or whatever but this was so
charming and fun like it's great I love this
world that they've built and uh just all the
different little flourishes and whatnot and
and yeah like God I wish I could just go walk
around that campus boy that's so pretty yeah
I love it yeah it's also super fun to see
how like him and Sully their relationship
how it started and then how it is there was
that one moment when Sully really turned into
becoming a team member when they were on the
roof and he starts helping them like get uh
when they're being chased by the cops yeah
but before that he was like just a jerk the
whole time then they had to talk because when
you think of the first movie you're like he's
nice yeah he's like a sweet guy and then you
get to see his change in this movie and I
like that yeah absolutely and I thought they
they played it you know in a way that uh felt
you know pretty graceful that worked quite
nicely I mean yeah they are like archetypical
but at the same time I thought the way that
they you know took yeah the overachiever and
the slacker and then kind of forced them toward
each other yeah like me and you exactly Tara
you carry me throughout this life yes yes
uh and you know I I've been carried by a lot
of great people in this life well I'm very
very grateful for and I'm grateful you are
one you are my Mike Wazowski oh so that means
you're my solely that's right that's right
we're so cute yeah yeah and I'm a nightmare
off camera we haven't had the talk yet that's
right you still you got to give me that one
last inspirational speech I do I've been writing
it for years but you're still I think you're
still scary though but yeah I know like seeing
the way that they ultimately took these characters
at this stage and then you know doing the
end Montage getting them to the point where
they are you know where we met them the first
time I just thought yeah it moved really nicely
toward all those things and and yes it was
Helen Mirren all right ah you had it right
yeah there's a lot of a lot of places in here
is Aubrey it was Aubry Plaza I was like she
only had like five lines but I was like that
has to be Aubry Plaza yeah yeah and there
was that John ratzenberger like I was sitting
here trying to like late in the movie I was
like oh yeah they're like Easter eggs Pixar
puts in everything yeah so there was uh at
least the John ratzenberger voice was there
as the yeti coming back from the first movie
and I swear he had lemons on his tie for the
yellow snow cones but uh I didn't see that
yeah or something I don't know that's what
it looked like to me I could be wrong but
but uh but yeah I didn't catch the Pizza Planet
truck or the or the room at USC or whatever
the the the the classroom where they all learned
in like you know but uh but just all the different
little flourishes all the different little
uh details and stuff like this is a movie
I would love to pause and scrub yeah because
like all just the monster versions of like
posters they'd have on the walls or advertising
and things like that and just yeah all the
different design flourishes I thought were
just so fun and and imaginative and for you
know somebody who loves horror and who loves
monsters anyway like this is I mean they made
fun of them for being so cute but like this
is like the best kind of blend of both it's
like it is really fun and bouncy and colorful
but at the same time like I I do like and
and very much appreciate just their take on
this world and all the different like fraternities
and sororities with all their you know the
way they went to to put you know the actual
Greek letters for some of it and then they'd
have like a spooky you know concept as one
of the letters and then each one spells out
a thing like this yeah just like really well
thought out yeah I especially like when well
of course like the highlight of their scare
but using all those like horror tropes like
in a movie with a thing and then the doll
um I don't know I just think this is such
a a creative film that still has uh Pixar
it does a really good job of this it still
has like a adults can watch it and love it
but it's still great for for kids to be like
except Pixar does a nice job of making it
more High are like comedy and like there's
some high bar like throwaway lines that it's
not all just like kid yeah it's not all fart
jokes yeah maybe you know what I mean no totally
because like this is and I'd have to go back
it's been a long time since I've seen the
original Monsters Inc and I know it's a lot
of people's one of their top Pixar joints
um and here like you know because I think
anytime especially a company like Pixar makes
a sequel there becomes the debate of like
is it great though and uh and this yeah I
thought was really nice because like it's
easily accessible for a young audience but
you know if you're an adult and especially
if you went to school uh I think this will
bring back yeah just a lot of those nostalgic
experiences and feelings and and yeah I thought
they captured that campus life in like a really
fun way that does definitely I think play
to people who have that experience as well
as people who might be looking forward toward
that experience yeah like man I wish I would
have went to a real school I just went to
performing art school and I was like we didn't
have the buffet thing people tell me that
they would have a cafeteria of a buffet and
they're like we could get frozen yogurt at
all times or frozen or ice cream like crazy
stuff and I'm like oh man also why doesn't
Disneyland do that where they have like Monsters
University but Monsters University food like
Mario Kart land in Universal Studios exactly
The Lure do that come on now make a special
monsters land and then plus you know we saw
how the cafeteria ran you could just take
whatever people discard put it right back
on the line yeah and then you save on uh garbage
disposal all that stuff yeah I would eat people's
leftover monster food I mean especially if
it's at a discount like I'm trying to save
some dollars you know so as long as they gave
me a little cut on the price I'd probably
only eat the leftovers yeah because it's expensive
someone's got to you know you don't want that
stuff to go to waste perfectly good all right
what's a little saliva am I right nothing
yeah but yeah I liked you know I mean it's
a kind of a classic story you know to to you
know opposite Misfits being put together and
then having to you know uh elevate a a team
of Misfits essentially to finally Triumph
but uh yeah I thought the way that they did
everything you know the way that it moved
was really nice was like really just rich
with uh you know fun dialogue and fun references
and fun not like you know Easter eggy references
but yeah just like fun flourishes of the Monster
World I thought the voice cast did a great
job yeah and yeah just like I love the world
like I I think that's that's the thing I like
the most is just the world like this this
felt like all the charms of like a Harry Potter
almost without getting too heavy right it
was still like on the lighter side like I
expect in every Pixar movie that I'm going
to like cry sure and this one I didn't but
I still felt the heart and it didn't feel
like it was like out of place I felt it like
a lot like they do such a good job of like
giving you the heart and doing like the pacing
and putting it at the right moment and building
up characters really nicely but I like how
Pixar does that yeah um and at the end it
was that like rom-com where there's always
somebody running at the end somewhere to an
airport after a car to be like hey wait um
don't go yeah yeah and I like that with them
yeah yeah totally yeah like it's interesting
because Pixar you do associate with this High
bar of yeah it's gonna be profound or something
and I definitely don't begrudge them like
something more fun more light like this and
especially when it is proportioned to the
way this particular movie is proportioned
I'm like yeah this was totally everything
it needed to be oh oh it's just getting to
class little guy my first day of class and
this school is over son you missed it oh
those guys must have a difficult life oh man
how's he ever gonna make it I don't know man
I'm praying for him that's like me and track
and they would tell me to run and then I'd
end up with like a 15 minute mile you've got
to keep at it Tara you're capable I mean I
am more than you can imagine but I don't want
to do it though I don't wanna I don't wanna
run down you're slacker Tara I am you are
a lazy bounce I know but now like yeah this
this isn't one of their more like profoundly
touching movies but I don't think it really
needed that and I think the way that it the
heart that it did have I think was really
lovely and uh and yeah I like the way the
plot unfolded because it was you know you
have the magic of just discovering Monsters
University you know that there will be obstacles
but I like the kind of linear nature of like
okay we got to the first scare class and then
through our own you know interpersonal you
know toxicity basically it was just because
we both got our own egos up you know uh it
leads to yeah this this chain of events that
gets them cast out of the class and then they
gotta earn their back with the games and when
the games ended and I thought the games were
really fun they were really imaginative yeah
and then when the games ended I had that thought
because at first it was like oh you know yes
he did it um and you're expecting that they'll
you know somehow win um and at that moment
even though I was really excited I was like
seems like that was pretty easy though it
seemed like that like and that was the point
I thought the movie was going to be like okay
like you know the wrap up it's fine but then
to go that extra uh Mile and be like okay
Sullivan cheated this and now we have to kind
of go off-road and prove ourselves in a different
way and there's like a a deeper All Is Lost
moment than just the idea that Mike that Sullivan
Sully doesn't think Mike is actually scary
there's you know there's the actual All Is
Lost when they go through the real door when
Mike is like going off the deep end and yeah
and I like that that doesn't result in like
well you know even though this was wildly
against the rules you guys did a great job
and you're just back like they still earn
the respect but they do get expelled their
teammates are spared the the fate and then
they work their way up you know in their own
natural way to becoming scarers and in a way
that also just subtly touches upon the idea
that even though it's easy to get very wrapped
up in and passionate about you know whatever
chosen school or institution you've gone to
that's not the only way to achieve success
and I think more and more in life that that
has become apparent it's like you know college
used to be like the the gateway to success
in this world and I think it's like nice that
they subtly included the idea that like hey
it's not the end of the world if that's not
your path and you could still succeed in your
chosen vocation without that I was kind of
a neat Nuance you know then yeah I mean that's
taken care of in a montage by the end but
I think that's okay because we know it's gonna
happen we've seen the first movie yeah and
uh and yeah I thought the story they chose
to tell was was quite conscientious and and
made for great opportunities for just a lot
of fun yeah I mean because like like I said
it takes nothing to be born scary just like
how they're trying to play like pretty bullies
like you don't have to do anything to be born
to look that way to fit in a fraternity or
whatever you just are kind of born and those
are your genetics like solely but um it takes
a lot to have to work to be up to the certain
level you're not given everything and even
though solely had more of a silver platter
kind of a thing handed to him with his name
it wasn't in inherently who he was so we still
got to see him grow with Mike through that
and people obviously who have to work their
way up and work a lot harder than the rest
and aren't nepo babies like you were saying
that that has aged up about this movie they
tend to be uh the the washed out matter that
like wins because they've learned so much
and I think when you go through that you um
end up being obviously a better person and
just having more like Street juice Street
knowledge which is nice yeah and two I mean
him you know actually learning actually putting
in some of the effort and then them coming
in at the end and actually just having a sort
of acceptance of like yeah you're not necessarily
scary but our teamwork and and like your brains
and my Brawn work really well together and
I thought yeah that was just a nice uh yeah
to come off yeah the overachiever who's been
handed nothing and then the underachiever
has been handed everything and then yeah the
way they grew them together I thought was
quite nice and to be in a time now where we
talk about nippo babies all the time we have
these like scandals about who gets into what
school because of what strings their parents
pulled and it doesn't go like really far into
that side of stuff but yeah like it's it's
funny that it has become sort of even more
relevant in that aspect of the conversation
yeah um but yeah I just pulled up the IMDb
there's a lot of great voices I mean you obviously
Billy Crystal John Goodman and Steve Buscemi
from the original but like I thought Helen
Mirren did a great job oh yeah uh and then
I I thought I recognized at the beginning
I thought that was John Krasinski as uh as
I believe that was him at the top the Frank
okay the guy who inspires him as a kid and
then uh you know Bill Hader was the slug was
yeah because they gave him his own post critics
which is fun and then Bobby moynihan's in
here you pointed out Aubry Plaza Nathan Fillion's
like always obvious yeah um and then Tyler
Levine Alfred Molina I was trying to figure
out his voice I thought he was a good addition
you were right on Charlie Day Charlie Dan
Dave Foley who's hilarious I love Dave Foley
from Kids in the Hall and stuff like that
um Sean Hayes is in here a lot of good voices
and yeah for those two to be paired together
as the two-headed guy I thought was yeah it
was a good call um yeah man and like you said
representation matters when they were looking
into the school we had never seen a scare
team and then they're they're the actual first
scare team that teams up together yeah so
it's like oh they can They're Gonna Change
the World they're scary stuff and that was
I mean without again that's something that's
also aged better you know all things considered
is when they go to Monsters Inc and they're
like oh wow literally there is no one kind
of monster there's everybody using their own
strengths I was like this is a good message
that doesn't feel like it was you know shoehorned
in because of social media or something right
and I was like yeah this is a really good
point and it doesn't necessarily solve everything
but it is like a good spiritual beat to have
yeah and it didn't feel expositional like
it was put there to force us to have the information
it just felt like a real moment and I I really
enjoyed that like yeah now they are the representation
for like a team Duo and it's it's great it's
like and they have a story to tell like they
were kicked out a couple of times so it used
to be a jerk like just a bunch of stuff that
uh makes it more heartfelt and that other
scarers can learn from to be like hey we're
not perfect we're just like normal people
and we messed up a lot yeah like we considered
ourselves failures but we're still here now
because we tried yeah yeah exactly we put
in the effort you know we we clearly have
something between us even if it's not exactly
what everybody is looking for or expecting
we have worth and we have more than enough
you know Manpower and will between the two
of us yeah yeah and I just pulled up I pulled
up a list of the the Easter eggs and stuff
yeah and
then you had the A113 which is that that room
uh I forget it's like a classroom in in USC
or something like that where a lot of them
uh studied or count lards there you go uh
and there was uh yeah the ball and all that
stuff and a few other things here you can
point out the other ones but I feel like John
ratzenberger uh the Pizza Planet truck and
the A113 are like always like the main ones
yeah but if there are any more Pixar Easter
eggs I mean feel free guys to point them out
to us um but yeah any any stray thoughts before
we we hit it and quit it no I would love to
go to Monsters University and obviously go
to the cafeteria that's the biggest thing
that matters to me that's actually I guess
we'll close on that is because we haven't
really talked about but I thought the animation
was absolutely gorgeous so amazing and like
the colors the designs of everything and the
way everything has like monstery little flourishes
and the use of color like they come and it
feels like full-on like Autumn or something
like that and then when things take a turn
for the more dire then you'll get these moments
where yeah the world is all desaturated and
you'll just have like the blue Banners are
kind of popping but everything else is very
gray and when they go into the human world
at the end it's very kind of gray and dreary
like you pointed out kind of enhancing those
tropes of a horror movie yeah uh yeah and
and for me like even though this is easily
like this is a family film it's not scary
per se I am all for like kid-friendly horror
stuff or stuff that's like accessible to kids
that can kind of help to feed you on your
journey as a budding young horror fan I think
this is you know this is good for that it's
a good one yeah absolutely so uh guys thank
you for joining us on this journey for this
semester at school very delightful and uh
and I'm excited to watch the original again
now that we've learned yeah me too yeah I
love the ride honestly I do whenever we're
in California Adventure you know gotta take
a break you gotta do it yeah so leave a like
on the video guys don't forget to subscribe
ring the bell and last but not least let's
do a picture of the day shut up let's do it
Mark Leach mark I want to see your scare buddy
I want to see you know I mean who knows if
you do some kind of like slithery thing I
mean I'm just going off your name right now
and I'm sure a lot of people make leech references
think about it leeches are pretty scary yeah
and pretty useful so you could be a a key
member of the monster's Community out here
you know you could like detox the monsters
you know God if they get to Juice Stop yeah
if they get all kid taminated yes you can
help remove that and also get some scares
in on the side you know I feel like leeches
are sort of like a horror movie Trope certainly
but they've also got their place in the circle
of life and even though you are not scary
in the way that we are repelled by you you
are formidable and if you wanted to scare
the pants off of us I bet you could but yeah
I believe in you so much scare energy to power
this whole studio for a year
we love you here at the Rio rejects the scariest
thing you could do I think would be to end
your pledge so don't go that far don't do
that you know I don't come on now yeah I don't
think you know don't get the sense this universe
is about trauma right you won't traumatize
anybody or the kids or anything just a little
scare juice yeah just a little bit yeah you
know that's all you need yeah that's all it's
a good hearted scare and I feel like that's
what you would deliver us yeah so be well
Mark we love you and we'll catch you on the
next one bye cheers foreign